yo what is up guys it is prestigio
matthew EG here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video and this video is
going to be my first impressions on the
new DLC they came out last Tuesday 27th
of the new character really of the
barrenness or sir ahem did miss ma'am
ma'am hammerlock the bareness i don't
know but it's the new dlc they came out
that has cryo skill trees and he you can
see here is it my gameplay I really
haven't played her for a signal to
significant amount of time so i can't
speak completely for all of her skill
trees or her late game early game she
does pretty well but then again
everything early game is pretty weak so
as you can see her cry Oh skill is that
she press you press after you press your
trigger the key and you launch out some
ice and it's a bunch of ice feat flurry
ha goes around an enemy dealing cry or
damage and I believe it just won it yet
just one enemy at a time specifically
the cryo shards might do damage to
multiple enemies I'll know its gate it's
kind of confusing since there is a huge
blizzard of cryo shards but it seemed it
focuses on one enemy and when the enemy
is getting hit by the cryo then you can
do extra damage to them because they're
taking crowded damage and that makes
them much more vulnerable to know any
other form of damage and also it has the
opportunity to freeze people that are
affected by it so it's been pretty good
for me so far some of the beginning
skills are a little lackluster in my
opinion like the entry level skills I
haven't really looked at the co-op ones
at all because the culture E is the
right tree i believe and i have a look
at that at all because i haven't been
playing co-op so i can't i can't speak
that but the other skills have been kind
of lackluster in what they appear to do
there's one skill it's you get stacks
for doing cry of damage and for each
stack you gain like plus i think it's
plus points Oh 15 cry oh damn
and point oh eight percent chance to
freeze or the other way around and you
can get up to a hundred stacks however
you only get you can only get one staff
/ enemy so once you we do it cryo damage
to an enemy the stacks go away and
that's kind of I'm like I'm probably not
gonna I don't know what the cooldown
time on each stack is um if it's
actually it technically if that's
infinite like if there's no cool on time
then it is a pretty good skill but if
there's a cool down time then you're
never going to hit a hundred enemies in
one fight unless it's just a really big
fight so that actually I'm actually
unsure on if that is a negative or a
pretty good positive but I have really
been joined the character overall I must
say it's DLC that i'm like i can't say i
recommend it yet because I'm played
through her skill trees which is a very
significant portion of it with basically
all of it so I can't say if I recommend
you guys get it probably once i get her
high level i'll do a skill tree of what
i think a really good skill set up is on
her so I like a lot of her dialogue is
like she's a super fancy rich lady she's
like oh I got bored running around in my
turbo mansion so I decided to come shoot
a bunch of things on elpis and annoy
hammerlock her brother as well because
she does like shooting things her
brother like studying but so there's all
the dialogue is kind of a high society
and it's a get it gives a good chuckle
it's pretty pretty different than the
other characters you got claptrap than
other like claptrap and nisha and if he
knows are all different in their own
right but this is something that we
haven't really had in the borderlands as
a playable character yet someone who's
like faint like fancy instead of just
being all rugged and crazy in some way
she's not really crazy just the extreme
of being super nobility and stuff so as
you can see oh and also one thing you
see you can see this is a pretty good
Jacob sniper rifle you start out with
I started I'm usually good to started
out with a purple pistol and a purple
sniper rifle because she's all rich and
for nobility so she has access to the
really good stuff so you start with a
better weapons than you would start with
as any of the other characters up from
that and that's all the characters in
berlin's presume so out of all the
characters you start with the best guns
with her on your initial playthrough
obviously once you start your second
playthrough your third playthrough with
her in all in true vault hunter mode and
ultimate vault hunter mode it's going to
be just guns that you have from your
previous playthrough and also I just
want to say guys sorry I'm a little bit
I've I got sick recently and my throat
is still a little scratchy so I
apologize if it feels like that or I'm a
little less enthusiastic because that is
the reason why so I think that's
basically everything I want to say on
the first impressions of her it is
something that I'm liking the skills
it's I'm still if young skills so far to
see if they're going to be unique and
add some cool down amps of the game all
keep you guys posted with the later
video on this character if I get to it
so I think I'm gonna end the video here
that's kind of getting near the end of
my gameplay so hope you guys have
enjoyed this a short amount of footage
and commentary on the new borderlands
dlc and check out my channel for any
other contents if you like borderlands
breezy cool since i have a lot of that
stuff and i'll see you all later peace
out guys